first of all how's mozzie doing man he's
obviously incarcerated I mean I I ain't
really talked to him personally but I
get his messages so and I I'm I know
talk to the people that he talked to so
is he like sending like texts and [ __ ]
in jail and all that well obviously the
legal way right yeah and it's a rue I
mean whatever right that's good man
because he's getting out he's got a year
right Dave yeah he got too long yeah
it's crazy man is that like um when you
see someone like Mozzy make that move to
go to like CMG and like go under that
Interscope umbrella as somebody like
yourself who's kind of been doing it
independently this whole time as he was
for so long does it make you kind of
think like what if I went the major
label route as well uh I should yeah I
always been thought like I wouldn't mind
doing it if it made sense whatever makes
sense for me I'm not really picky I'm
not really trying to do all the extra
[ __ ] I'm whatever makes the most sense
I'm I [ __ ] with that but yeah yeah let
me make the most